we are less than a week away from two
crucial senate run-ups in georgia that
will decide which party controls the u.s
senate
republican incumbents david perdue and
kelly loffler are
being challenged by democrats jon ossoff
and reverend rafael warnock
more than two and a half million people
have already voted in
those two races a record for a georgia
runoff election
both president trump and president-elect
biden will campaign in the state next
week
cbs news political contributor and
democratic strategist
joel payne joins us from washington dc
good morning joel i've got georgia on my
mind i know georgia's on your mind so
i'm so glad to have you joining us today
how are you
i'm doing well thanks for having me so
the democrats need to win
both of these seats in order to flip the
senate what are you hearing from your
sources on the ground about their
chances of doing that
democrats feel optimistic but i think
they're also realistic listen
in a runoff election that's not on
election day that's in a state like
georgia which is yes it's trending
purple but as someone on the ground told
me it's a red shade of purple
i think democrats still understand it's
really a long shot i think turnout's
important i think
those early vote numbers you just cited
the record 2.5 million early vote
numbers
are really encouraging to democrats but
i think it's really about ground game
over the next
96 or so hours and i think you're going
to see democrats really pull out all the
stops to mobilize you talked about
president-elect biden kamala harris was
in state earlier this week
they're going to have all their heavies
there in state because we all know the
senate rest on this
stacey abrams of course was credited by
many for helping
joe biden win georgia because of her
turnout efforts in the black community
will those same voters turn out in this
runoff especially since
voters tend not to turn out in as high
numbers during runoff
i think that's a good question the
electorate is probably going to look a
little bit different
one of the things in talking to people
on the ground in georgia they'll say
that stacey abrams and her folks the way
they organized
was really service oriented and i'd be
curious to see whether they can take
that same approach for this
runoff election which is again 45 days
after the general election and
kind of in the middle of a really
interesting political season
for georgians stacey abrams has really
been viewed on democrats
among democrats as kind of the mvp of
this cycle for putting georgia in play
not just in this runoff but really for
helping joe biden deliver the state
two months ago what do you mean by
service oriented
well that's interesting right so going
and organizing people
around what their needs are helping
people get unemployment checks or
helping people connect to social
services
and using that to register voters that's
actually something that democrats have
used in the state
to be effective also it's not just
african americans i know that that's a
niche issue people like to talk about
it's also asian americans and latinos in
georgia
are really surging populations and
abrams and her organizers have really
taken advantage of that as well
so true so president trump has of course
made unfounded attacks against georgian
election officials claiming that that
election was was rigged essentially
how do you think that might affect his
supporters in terms of
them even coming out to the polls do
they still trust the process
that's a good question i know that
georgia republican officials have to be
concerned about that i mean
essentially what president trump is
asking georgia republicans to believe
is that his election was uh was was
corrupt in some way but all these other
state officials
in georgia were in on it that brian kemp
and the secretary of state were all
republicans who voted for
donald trump that they worked with
democrats to steal the election from him
that's a tall tale to tell the the the
backside of that is
whether georgians will actually trust
the process georgia georgia voters who
like donald trump are they going to
trust the process so you have this
interesting dynamic here of where you
need donald trump to heat up the base if
you're a republican but you're also
concerned about him
depressing excitement and depressing
enthusiasm so joel tell us are we in for
another election week or should we know
the results on election night
well i would put it like this if we know
what happens on election night my census
is probably a good night for republicans
because it's probably an easy
victory for purdue and lofler if it
takes a little bit longer that's
probably better for democrats because
that means it's a closer election and
really democrats best chance here is if
it's a close election that they can eke
out
speaking of purdue and lafleur what do
you think are their chances
um you know how will the fact that they
support the two thousand dollar stimulus
check
how do you think that'll affect them
quickly because we don't have a ton of
time
they did what they needed to do i think
what's interesting is how this
this race has really got shrouded in
race kelly loffler
has been campaigning with someone who is
purported to be a part of the ku klux
klan
she's been making attacks on rafael
warnock so that has
really become kind of a central issue in
the race over the last
72 hours or so we'll see if that carries
it to election day
joel payne thank you